Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
soy Juice Muñoz en esta edición nos
acompaña jacu Pérez ambientalista y
activista político ecuatoriano
recordemos que en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2021 se quedó a poco
más de 30.000 votos de pasar a segunda
vuelta Muchas gracias yacu Pérez por
estar en la entrevista de France 24
a usted un placer saludar y a todos
quienes nos escuchan usted ha dicho
recientemente que el presidente
Guillermo lasso está secuestrado por el
correísmo y que el juicio político
posible en su contra nacería muerto por
qué
Porque tanto lo social cristianos de la
derecha ecuatoriana y el correísmo que
también está alineado en la derecha
política del Ecuador
tienen al presidente
sin poder prácticamente dar un paso
hemos visto como la justicia
empieza de a poco
hacer lo que ellos piden el señor glass
está libre y ahora le van a dar las
devolver las pensiones vitalicias que es
doloroso para los Ecuatorianos es
indignante lo que está sucediendo igual
una ex ministra de vivienda que estuvo
en la embajada de Argentina salió libre
el ex secretario jurídico de la
presidencia está libre el ex secretario
de la Sinaí está libre y así van a
continuar es decir el correísmo si no es
a las buenas que también hay un pacto
con el presidente lasso lo actúa de
manera beligerante a través de El
chantajes y en este rato creo que el
presidente lasso está secuestrado por el
correísmo por los cristianos por la
narcopolítica que es grave para los
ecuatorianos
pero usted cree que Guillermo lasso debe
mantenerse en el cargo ante estas
acusaciones de peculado También conocido
como malversación
el presente lazo comenzó mal recordemos
que cuando estuvimos nosotros en la
segunda vuelta él se comprometió
públicamente ante los delegados de la
oea a abrir las urnas al siguiente día
rompió su palabra luego aparecieron los
Pandora papers donde él está seriamente
involucrado con dineros que sacó hacia
los paraísos fiscales ahí hay un proceso
penal se salvó de ese proceso y luego
vino todo unos conflictos de
irregularidades en el Palacio de
carondelet con todo la trama de
corrupción de una red de corrupción
increíble y eso le ha hecho perder toda
legitimidad Entonces el presente de la
República lo mejor que podría haberlo
hecho a su tiempo es convocar a un gran
acuerdo nacional este rato es un poco
tarde creo que ya no tiene ya nadie les
cree y por otro lado creo que el
presidente de la república
lo menos por dignidad de vía lo
renunciar y de esta manera pagaba toda
la llama ese rato le veo bien difícil
que vaya a poder gobernar los dos años
que le faltan porque el juicio político
también si bien estamos Este rato en el
juicio político pero probablemente no
venga la censura y destitución porque él
tiene el poder Él lo va a comprar a los
asambleístas con cargos públicos con
dinero lastimosamente en el Ecuador los
asambleístas están cotizando su voto Y
eso es triste para el país triste para
América Latina no tenemos experiencia en
estos casos de un buen enjuiciamiento se
han hecho de una manera
O sea destituido a otros presidentes
pero es la primera vez que se da un
impeishman una vez un juicio político y
que probablemente No precede usted
piensa que le ha faltado a lasso un plan
de gobierno o más bien no le han dejado
gobernar
Yo creo que el presente lazo nunca pensó
ser presidente él aún confunde gerenciar
un banco que ejercer la presidencia de
la República su indolencia su
insensibilidad ha sido extremo porque
hay una estampida de del pueblo del
Ecuador que huye del país con una
delincuencia que es único en la historia
del país veintiséis muertos asesinados
por día Quizás lo único que le salva es
las medidas que tomó para la pandemia
pero en lo demás los jóvenes no tienen
universidad no tienen trabajo los
hospitales sin medicamentos sin médicos
sin enfermeras las escuelas se caen los
las carreteras por este invierno y eso
que no viene todavía el fenómeno del
niño es intransitable los campos están
abandonados con una siete millones de
Ecuatorianos de los 18 millones que está
en pobreza multidimensional de ellos dos
millones Ecuatorianos viven con menos de
dos dólares diarios es decir estamos
ante una crisis nunca antes vista ni
siquiera en el tiempo de mahuad cuando
cayó en el año 1999 hemos tocado fondo Y
eso es grave para los Ecuatorianos sí le
quería preguntar precisamente por eso
usted haga anunciado un pacto con el
exministro correísta Gustavo Larrea y su
compañero ha llegado a decir que Ecuador
vive la peor crisis de su historia Me
podría ampliar un poco más porque cree
que esta afirmación es cierta
porque antes no teníamos un
una delincuencia vinculada a la
corrupción y al narcotráfico había
corrupción si en el gobierno de correa
de Moreno pero no había con el
narcotráfico creo que el gobierno de
lasso tiene gente vinculada su gobierno
al narcotráfico por eso es que no hace
nada es un infierno las cárceles ahora
está poniéndose de moda las vacunas
nunca antes en el Ecuador habíamos visto
a una persona atada explosivos o sea eso
es ni siquiera vivíamos eso Solamente
era en Colombia o en en México Incluso
se dicen de acuerdo a los últimos datos
que solamente en tiempos de Pablo
Escobar en la Colombia de Escobar en
donde
asesinaban 26 personas por día se ahora
se ha llegado a ese momento es
absolutamente crítico no tenemos un
futuro es tenu
claro obscuro una incertidumbre
todos los Ecuatorianos que quieren
producir que quieren invertir no lo
pueden hacer porque están con miedo de
las vacunas con miedo de que salen de
las de sus casas pero no sé si
retornarán es decir hay un hay un miedo
hay un terror por parte de la inmensa
mayoría de los ecuatorianas los únicos
que están tranquilos son los que están
con guardaespaldas los del gobierno los
de la asamblea la gente que tiene dinero
pero el resto de Ecuatorianos en
absoluta indefensión y como revertiría
yaku Pérez esta situación de seguridad
por la que pasa Ecuador
Bueno siempre nosotros dijimos que no
estamos de acuerdo con la izquierda
colonial autoritaria y corrupta que pasó
por el Ecuador ni con el neoliberalismo
con esa derecha recalcitrante que
solamente piensa en el bolsillo en el
dinero y se olvida de la pobreza de la
dignidad de los empobrecidos
Ecuatorianos y por eso planteamos la
tercera vía la tercera vía que
justamente tiene un enfoque ecológico
social guiado por la ética y la
honestidad esa tercera vía que es la
inclusión de todos los sectores sociales
del país no solamente los sectores
indígenas Campesinos de izquierda sino
también los empresarios honestos también
los choferes también los gremios de los
artesanos de Los profesionales capaz de
entre todos construir el Ecuador que
soñamos en donde se pague la deuda
social se pague la deuda ecológica pero
todos absolutamente todos guiados por la
ética
7.600 millones de dólares cada año
se van
se hacen humo es decir va en corrupción
en el no paran las los impuestos en el
servicio de rentas internas no se paga
los impuestos en las aduanas ahí está la
corrupción con siete mil seiscientos
millones de dólares cada año se puede
hacer carreteras construir escuelas
construir hospitales mejorar las vías
darles canales de riego darles créditos
al sector indígena sector campesino al
sector agropecuario que tanto necesita
es decir una tercera vía si es posible
tenemos recursos naturales tenemos un
pueblo que sabe trabajar un pueblo que
es honesto un pueblo que es generoso un
pueblo que es laborioso pero
desventajosamente ya no creen cuando
llegan al poder personas que no están en
condiciones que no están a la altura de
las circunstancias que no son estadistas
no están pensando en las próximas
generaciones y no solamente en las
próximas elecciones se habla mucho de
que estos grupos armados son
transnacionales es necesario también una
colaboración activa de Estados Unidos o
también vías como la posible regulación
de cultivos ilícitos para combatir este
tipo de inseguridad que vive Ecuador
El problema del narcotráfico es un
problema complejo grave y transnacional
no se puede solucionar solamente del
Ecuador y no se puede solucionar
solamente invirtiendo dándoles más balas
dándoles más armas al ejército a la
policía que está bien hacerlo eso pero
no es suficiente si no destinamos
combatir la pobreza combatir el
desempleo combatir la corrupción es
imposible salir pero ese es un enfoque
lo otro es internacional y creo que cada
vez más hay que debatir y hablar duro
duro de la posibilidad de una
una legalización de algunos de algunos
tipos de drogas es decir creo que hay
que ir a la despenalización de algunas
drogas en el en el país y no solamente
en el país sino a nivel mundial creo que
ese fue un criterio que lo dijo el ex
presidente de Rodrigo Borja lo ha dicho
el expresidente Juan Manuel Santos
Premio Nobel de la paz creo que en ese
criterio hay personas que el rato que
acaba el negocio ilícito de las drogas
se vuelve un ya un negocio lícito pues
prácticamente tenemos ahí las
experiencias de de la legalización del
alcohol en Estados Unidos y en muchas
partes del mundo con eso se acaba con
eso se vuelve ya no se vuelve apetecido
ya no se vuelve codicioso el
narcotráfico creo que es una de las
medias y por eso es importante un
acuerdo internacional entre los
productores de la droga Colombia Perú
Bolivia Brasil y entre los consumidores
como es en este caso estados es
paradójico abajo en América Latina en
los países del sur se producen La Roca
para la droga para el consumo de los
países del Norte así como en los países
del Norte se producen las armas para el
consumo de las armas en los países del
sur Esa es la paradoja Y eso hay que
resolver
jacuzzi nos acaba el tiempo le agradezco
mucho por haber estado en la entrevista
de France 24
un placer un lindo día y muchas gracias
También a nuestra audiencia Pueden
seguir más contenidos como este en
France 24 y en France 24.com
[Música]